alexandre vient de conquérir l'egypte
mais il ne veut pas la diriger comme un
simple mortel à la manière des grecs
il attend de l'oracle qui le proclame
dieu pour qu'il puisse prendre le titre
de pharaon
où la houle lorsqu'alexandre arrive
enfin au temple il tient à pénétrer seul
dans cette pièce
allez rempli dansant ici se trouvait le
saint des saints lieu dans lequel
alexandre n'avait certainement pas eu le
droit de pénétrer même s'il a déposé une
offrande probablement un agneau cela ne
peut être qu'ici puis il a demandé
suis-je un dieu toutes les sources
parvenus jusqu'à nous s'accordent pour
dire que l'oracle le proclama
effectivement dieu
fort de son nouveau statut divin
alexandre quitte la petite oasis et se
lance dans la construction du plus grand
empire que le monde ait jamais connu un
empire qui s'étend de l'europe à l'inde
trois siècles plus tard
peu de temps avant la naissance du
christ l'egypte a toujours à sa tête une
figure divine cléopâtre une jeune grec
descendante d'un des généraux
d'alexandre fasciné par les conquêtes du
grand guerrier
elle est déterminée à l'imiter et même à
faire mieux que lui
alexandre est mort à l'âge de 32 ans à
23 ans et cléopâtre l'a déjà surpassé
elle fait son entrée dans rome en tant
que reine d'égypte et maîtresse de jules
césar
l'homme le plus puissant du monde
antique
cléopâtre est né en égypte à alexandrie
ville fondée par alexandre le grand
c'est une ville magnifique réputé pour
ses temples et ses palais son phare est
l'une des sept merveilles du monde
sa bibliothèque la plus grande de tous
les temps et son école de médecine est
universellement reconnu cette ville
l'une des plus grandes du monde antique
est gouverné depuis trois siècles par la
famille de cléopâtre les tollés mais des
rois grecque qui règne sur l'egypte